>>> AS HE'S GOING TO GATHER,
HE'S GETTING IT LOCKED UP THERE.
>> HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO GUARD?
I'M GETTING CLIPPED ON THE
SCREEN AND STILL PURSUING.
THERE WAS A ONE ON ONE MATCHUP.
IT WAS NO SCREENER.
MY ONLY THING IS YOUR HANDS WERE
HERE, YOU JUST HAVE TO GET THEM
HERE?
YOU FOLLOW ME OR NO?
>> I FOLLOW YOU, BUT IT'S SO
HARD WHEN HE'S GOING TO GRAB ME.
IT'S CLEVER.
IT LOOKS LIKE A FOUL, BUT IF
I'VE GOT MY HANDS, RIGHT
ALONGSIDE HIM, HE'S GOING TO
BRAB MY ARM?
>> I UNDERSTAND.
I UNDERSTAND.
>> ITS DO, TOO.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> THAT'S A CALM DISCUSSION.
ED MALLOY IN HIS 19th SEASON.
A FORMER PLAYER AT THOMAS
JEFFERSON UNIVERSITY, PLAYER OF
THE YEAR IN THE EARLY '90s.
THERE'S THE PLAY THAT DURANT IS
CALLED FOR THINKS THIRD FOUL.
THAT WAS VERY NICELY EXPLAINED,
I THOUGHT.
>> Chris: SUCH A COOL EXCHANGE.
AS A PLAYER, THAT'S ALL YOU
WANT.
WHAT YOU HATE ARE REFEREES WHO
WON'T EXPLAIN IT.
NOT THAT THERE'S MANY LIKE THAT,
BUT THAT'S WHAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
ED IS NO, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE ONE ON ONE.
I KNOW IT'S TOUGH.
THAT'S ALL YOU WANT.
I HOPE THE FANS ENJOY THAT JUST
AS MUCH AS I